recently I took a job working at a camp
with at-risk boys where well there I
will live and work as a counselor in a
house with the kids any advice for
working with young people with
behavioral issues yeah it depends what
the behavioral issues are so I don't
know what out risk means but so I can't
be too specific but what I can tell you
is that almost nothing beats listening
you know like take a kid for a walk
let them talk like listen to them ask
them questions
you know because most disturbed people
and maybe even most people don't
actually have anyone they can talk to
and they need to talk first of all to
find out that someone actually cares
enough to listen so it's sort of like a
validation of the fact that they exist
and second so that they can sort out
their own thoughts so as a beginning
counselor the best thing you can do is
listen you don't want to give advice
really you know because what you want
you can ask questions that might lead
someone in an advisable direction but
the problem with giving advice is that
people are much more likely to remember
something and to implement it if they've
thought it up in their own words I think
that actually produces a kind of
neurological transformation the idea has
to be engendered from within it's one of
the prime dicta of of psychoanalytic
theory for example I think it's a really
good one
so yeah when and with regards so Brendon
crystal says trippy snakes and retinas
yeah like it's really specific so this
woman named no I probably can't remember
her name II any either she she wrote a
book about trees and serpents she's a
UCLA professor the fruit the tree and
the serpent I think it's called she
showed quite clearly that not only do
our retinas say directly detect snakes
but they do a better job in the bottom
half of the retina and that we're really
good at detecting the camouflage
patterns that are characteristic of
snakes - snakes have these like Diamond
powders which are very very rare and we
have specialized circuitry for detecting
those and there was recent research
conducted that showed that children 6
months old who had never been exposed to
anything even resembling his
take out an automatic response to snakes
and so it actually seems to be innate
not just not just easily learned so
that's really quite interesting